These things have been tucked away. And, you know, some of our scholars come to
use them and look at them to say, "Oh wow, this is a daguerreotype."  But the
biographies or the--you know, the autobiographical value--you know, people
sitting for these images, even if
it's being paid for by potentially
someone else. It's important, you know and
to know the context, you know, within
which these images were taken, and
therefore, kind of, the the memories that
would be associated with them
historically.  It gives the images more
depth and weight, right. And so I think,
you know, you have to spend time with
these materials to get to know the
materials. I mean, it sounds kind of weird
but that's research for you. You
know, you do a lot of work to get
the essence of--you know, it's the
questions that we ask. But it's also
developing a knowledge base where
you can be very articulate as it relates
to the time periods, but potentially
the people that you're looking at.
I mean, the calico dress she's
wearing in this picture is not only
telling of of her class, but also what
she had access to. She may have been a
seamstress, or someone else may have made
the dress. But the fact that she's
wearing this type of dress
in this kind of image, you know--and
it's an embroidered box as well, so
it was very personal. This may have been
a coin purse.
You know, it's like it was cut and then sewn on.
An 1830s, 40s daguerreotype
such as this:
of an African American
man. Who...
I don't know what his occupation would've been.
Daguerreotypes at this time
would have been expensive. So he could
have been a driver, owned by someone. Who
knows? He could have been a freedman like,
Frederick Douglas. But there's no
documentation.
But when we put all these pieces together:
1829, 1840s, going back to
1818,
there's a pattern here that develops.
He potentially was a free man.
Where could he have lived? Maybe Ohio.
Philadelphia. New York. Potentially.
But he also could have
been enslaved, and this
was a way for his master, or owner, to
document his property.
We don't know that.
So all these different artifacts, these
different materials, tell a part of a
larger story. And each of them had their--
you know, they have their own stories.
But, you know, it's one of these,
you know, grand opportunities to try to
create sense, make sense, of history using
these materials, these artifacts.
And we have that opportunity each and every day.